the thing I love about you all you can  always say you're family and you're  going to stick together at the end of it  that we are it's been 13 years since the  Kardashian family lost their patriarch  Robert Kardashian senior Kim paid  tribute to her late father on her at  Friday honoring his memory with  priceless home videos okay this is my  dad the throwback footage shows adorable  appearances by mom Kris and big sis  Kourtney Kimmy also shares how much her  dad meant to the entire reality TV  family writing we miss him every single  day  but today we wanted to share with you a  glimpse of who he was it was hard to  find footage of our dad since he loved  to film us and was always behind the  camera but here's a little look into who  he was to us